Bob honey who just do stuff and I want
to make it clear this is out now in
paperback but you are working on the
next book which I believe is Bob honey
sing Jimmy crack corn that's a
continuation of this book yeah it's a
direct continuation of this and and when
you wrote this book when we talked about
it you talked a little bit about
possibly whether or not some characters
in it were inspired by people in real
life but you were a little cagey about
it you've since painted there's a
picture of there's a there's a character
in the book called
landlord mm-hmm and when I was reading
the story I thought is this possibly who
I think it might be I'm not sure you
didn't say you've since painted a
picture and a painting of the character
the landlord and you brought it with you
is that right yeah well I paint as I'm
writing so this was was one of those and
some some people find a familiar face in
the paintings or in the descriptions
let's take a look at this is the person
and and I don't know if you see it's all
I guess it's in the eye of the beholder
it's obviously Ron Perlman yeah
we'll let it go let it go that when can
we when can we expect the next book
September okay yeah Bob honey Singh's
Jimmy crack corn is out in September all
right well I want to make sure we get
the word out honey who just do stuff is
in is available right now in paperback
so make sure you go out and get this and
of course Bob honey sing Jimmy crack
corn out in September and for more
information on core and this is really
important
go to core response dot org they're
doing the Lord's work
Sean Penn so cool really thank you
[Applause]